i hear that we share a um secret nemesis  yes  yes we do um i am a huge fan of the  voice so  yes i love watching people's dreams come  true me too so  i cry every episode but um i'm always  just rooting against blake shelton  because my favorite artist is never on  his team no  disrespect to those artists they are all  incredible obviously but like he just  wins  so much okay i'm not going to say that  on the show no i'm kidding  i'm just kidding no he does win a lot so  it is our goal um collectively is the  other coaches to beat him  yeah and i'm with you on that until  ariana comes then our collective goal  will be to  not lose so tremendously so to ariana  grande  yeah yeah one of my favorite moments  from this season was your team  singing pov aria oh my gosh  oh my gosh incredible i love that song  yes want more fun stuff  i thought so check out these videos  floating around my head  this one is really cool i'm just saying  no pressure